et puis catherine tasca accède
finalement le principe des cartes
illimitées pour le cinéma après une
bataille avec les réseaux de
distribution la ministre la culture de
la communication constate le succès de
cette formule une interview accordée à
l'atelier terre que l'initiative
d'élargissement de cette politique
d'abonnements en elle-même a aussi des
aspects positifs
je crois qu'il est important d'amener un
public plus large qui n'est peut-être
pas prêt à payer le plein tarif dans les
salles de cinéma
si ces formules d'abonnement hamel un
accroissement du public
elles peuvent se transformer en une
bonne évolution
il y à des conditions pour ça il faut
absolument que ce système des cartes
soit ouvert sur le réseau des salles
indépendantes
si leur public peut avoir accès aussi
aux salles offertes par les grands
circuits et réciproquement et bien au
fond nous aurons avancé vers une
politique peut-être plus dynamique et
dans l'intérêt des publics ce qu'il doit
être notre préoccupation à tous